last time on true fear I told you about
my creepy experiences with the hobo King
if you haven't seen that episode I'll
leave a link so you can go see it I've
also been talking with more people used
to live at that building who saw my hobo
King video and I've come across some new
information and horror stories so if
you'd like to see a part two to that
video leave a like and let me know in
the comments so basically we had to
leave the apartment as it became
unlivable due to the bug they were
supposed to treat our apartment right
away but they cared about money a lot
more than the well-being of their
tenants and that is today's horror story
no but when that happened we found
ourselves hotel hopping for a while as
mentioned in Episode two it was student
housing so the school would put us up in
these nearby hotel I know that sounds
cool like some awesome Zack and Tony
[ __ ] so the apartment complex manager
kept lying about when they would
actually be treating our apartment so
the school kept putting us in these
hotels for one day at a time
and different hotels would fill up on
different days so we had to move to a
different hotel almost every night and
it just got to the point where it was
exhausting couple that with the fact
that we were in classes and had our own
lives to deal with and had to constantly
fight with the apartment management to
get our unit fixed and the whole hotel
thing wasn't a lot of fun it was also
kind of a health detriment we didn't
have a kitchen to cook in nor did we
have any place that we could store food
and we had to go out and get fast food
all the time and that's where this story
began at an extended-stay America in
Woodland Hills California so I had
gotten out of class and checked into the
hotel and I was feeling pretty hungry so
I decided to go out and find somewhere
that I could get food in the hotel
there's all these super long hallways
and our room was at the end of the last
hallway so I'm headed out of there and I
see this door partially open at the end
of one of the halls and this older woman
standing in the dark so I think oh she
must be getting ready to go out and
leave her room well turns out I was
right
in a way once I get closer she walks out
of the room and she's standing in the
hall right it seems like she's looking
at me but when I saw her eyes it was
more like she was listening with past me
or looking through me at something like
her head was pointed in my direction but
it's almost like she didn't see me at
all she was in her own world and in this
world of hers there was a ghost standing
just past where I was I know it's hard
to picture but that's the best way I can
really describe it so that was
unsettling but not as unsettling as what
would come next the voice it was like
something out of a horror movie and what
she said didn't make it any better
now I don't remember her exact words so
I'm just paraphrasing but it was
something along the lines of why hello
Gerald why don't you come in and have
some supper make you some supper and
then she actually started laughing and
meanwhile I just didn't even think about
responding to any other I just kept
walking and never looked back she kept
talking as I walked away but I didn't
hear so yeah that was one of the
creepier things I'd ever seen but I
guess it could have been like a prank or
something or maybe she had a bluetooth
on but I didn't see maybe I was honestly
just trying to come up with an excuse
for my own comfort at that point but
after that I went out got some food and
came back and at that point I had pretty
much forgotten about it all but then I
turned into that hallway again and what
do I see in the same exact spot where
the woman had wandered out before there
was a police officer taking down some
notes and the door that the woman came
out of was open and the place was
cleared out I never found out what
happened that night while I was getting
food but I still do wonder if I had just
been lucky to have not been a victim
clearly something went down while I was
gone and it was big enough to get the
cops called and start an investigation
what stuck with me more than anything
was the look in that woman's eye she
just looked so Hollow after thinking
more about the situation I came up with
the theory that she was having some kind
of flashback in her head possibly a
trauma induced reaction what led me to
this theory well first I want to analyze
why she was even staying at this hotel
this isn't in like a touristy part of LA
it's at least thirty minutes away from
the beach 30 minutes away from Universal
and 45 minutes away from Hollywood so
that left me with
possibility she's visiting family or
there's something wrong at home causing
her to have to stay in the hotel the
same reason that I was technically
staying there based on her behavior I've
decided to explore the ladder as that
seems more likely to me we have very
little to go off of in the situation
really just what she said which
unfortunately I don't remember it
perfectly word for word this was before
I started doing true fear so I didn't
think to write it down or anything but I
think her dialogue does offer some
possible clues as to what was going on
so first there's this character Gerald
who she seemed to be talking to based on
the way that she was talking to him and
the fact that she asked him to come in
for supper Gerald may have been her
husband or possibly her son at the
beginning of the interaction she seemed
kind of surprised to see Gerald so I
took this as they had been apart for
some time and maybe she was daydreaming
or hallucinating about seeing him again
that's why I think this may have been
trauma related in some way for example
if Gerald was her husband I get the
sense that he hurt her and abandoned her
in some way causing her to fall into a
deep depression and replayed the idea
that she has in her head of when they
would see each other again this idea is
supported by the fact that she starts
laughing which leads me to believe that
in her head Gerald responded to her and
said something that she found funny this
would also explain why she was waiting
in the hotel room and came out when she
saw me it wouldn't be so different from
when you see a dog waiting by the window
for their master to return if she truly
did have some kind of traumatic
experience with gerald it's possible
that this was just her way of dealing
with
I'm no expert on the human brain but if
we do go with the story about the woman
in Gerald I shudder to think about what
may have caused her to get kicked out of
the hotel and the cops called I really
have nothing to go on here but my gut
tells me that her perceived reunion with
Gerald may not have gone that well and
possibly brought up some repressed scars
again I have no actual idea what went
down but I imagine a delusional old
woman screaming and crying at an unseen
presence in the middle of a hall one
that would have scared some of the hotel
guests and staff the fact that she was
removed from the room tells me that she
may have even gotten violent towards one
of the other guests if me simply walking
by was enough to trigger delusions of
the past imagine what danger someone
trying to calm or down might have been
in that's it for this episode of truth
here but you won't want to miss out in
the next one where I'll be telling you
about the gunman on my subway train
don't worry this is going to be the most
intense episode yet and I actually have
some pretty scary raw footage of what
went on that day so if you don't want to
miss it be sure to subscribe to Susie's
world we've got new [ __ ] every other
week to ring that desk bell for
notifications and I'll see you in the
next one assuming we both survive
[Music]
you
[Music]